-Welcome back to "Late Night,"
We're here with
Hillary Rodham Clinton
and Louise Penny.
Louise, I have a question,
you obviously had an expert who
was telling you these are things
that could actually happen.
Being a Canadian, were there
times that American politics
as explained to Hillary to you,
seem beyond comprehension?
[ Laughter ]
-What?
You know, I have to say, Seth.
And something I'm not sure
whether you all know,
but this is Canadian
Thanksgiving today.
So I want to say
happy Thanksgiving.
-Happy Thanksgiving.
-And there's no way
on Canadian Thanksgiving to say
something ungracious
about our wonderful neighbor.
-I mean yeah.
-But what I will say about
Canada versus the united States
is Justin Trudeau.
-Mm-hmm. Yeah. Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-That's my answer to any
political question.
-That's your trump card? Okay.
-Sounds like a sequel to me.
[ Laughter ]
-Was it -- were there times,
you know, I think this is
a question of anybody writing
fiction that takes place
in Washington, D.C. these days,
was there time where
truth has become so strange
that it is hard to write
a world that is any different,
or even harder to believe,
than what we're living through
every day?
-Yeah. You know, I think,
you know, Louise is just
an extraordinary writer
and creates characters
and conceives plots that are
so fascinating and draw you in,
but truly what's been going on
in Washington,
I think beggars the imagination.
It's hard to make it up.
-I think, had we written this
Five, six years ago people would
have said, "No, this is insane,
this is ridiculous.
-yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Now, actually, even in the
course of writing it,
it has gone essentially from
fiction to nonfiction.
I mean, what Hillary was talking
about, frighteningly enough
a year and a half ago with me,
when we were discussing it
is now coming true.
-Yeah, because I've always said,
"Look, we're gonna get out
of Afghanistan at some point.
And, when we do we gotta remain
vigilant,
because the terrorists
are not going away.
And now in addition to the
Taliban and al-Qaeda,
we now have this ISIS branch
there and they have not
given up on attacking us,
our friends, and our allies.
So people have to be
aware of that.
And obviously our leaders
and those who have to protect us
have to pay attention.
And we just have to be smart
and try to think ahead
about what they're trying to do
and what they're going to
aim at next,
in order to protect ourselves.
-I think it was May,
hopefully I'm right here,
where you referred to
Afghanistan as a wicked problem.
And basically you predicted that
When we left this would happen,
the Taliban would take over.
I think everybody
was caught off guard
maybe by the speed
it was gonna happen.
But if it had happened
in a week,
if it had happened six months,
if it had happened in a year,
it was going to happen.
Do you think then --
putting aside how we left,
do you think it was
the right decision to leave?
-You know,
it's really difficult to answer
that because
in the former administration
the United States Government
under Trump made an agreement
that actually Trump's
former national security adviser
McMaster said
was a surrender agreement
to get out by May 1st.
so when the
United States Government
tells an adversary we're leaving
and then the adversary goes
"Oh, great, let's get ready
for them to leave."
Let's go to the village and talk
to Seth, the head guy.
And say, "Seth bring home all
your soldiers or you guys
are gonna be wiped out."
And, "Let's use our money
from the opium trade to buy
favor and figure out
how we're gonna take over,
not just the countryside
but go into the cities,
and particularly Kabul."
That's all entrain and the deal
that Trump made with the Taliban
was, "Okay, you're leaving we
won't kill Americans
because you're going to leave."
And so, when Biden comes in
he's, like, left with
this total fait accompli,
and his decision has to be
either, get out
in a responsible way.
Which was to push the deadline
a little bit,
or put in more troops because
they're going to attack us
and we have to
protect ourselves.
It was an absolute, you know,
Hobson's choice.
So, getting out
was going to happen
once the Trump agreement
was reached.
How we get out, how we protect
ourselves going forward,
how we try to help those Afghans
who stood with us
and were taking on enormous risk
and I'm particularly focused on
all the women who were
in the government,
they were journalists,
they were in business,
they were in education
and health care.
Those are the people that I hope
we can continue to try to
assist and as we also
protect ourselves.
It's complicated.
But, yeah.
It's something that once
that was decided was entrain.
-I want to finish with one last
question about the book.
Your husband Bill was here
with James Patterson
and he admitted
that they were writing a book,
and that you would be a little
competitive about sales.
[ Laughter ]
Do you share
this competitive nature?
-Oh, certainly not. No.
[ Laughter ]
-I know it's impossible to ask
Louise on Canadian Thanksgiving.
-Yeah, she's so gracious.
-Justin Trudeau.
-We heard.
-I just wish everyone well.
-You wish everyone well.
How very Louise of you.
I want to thank very much
Hillary Rodham Clinton
and Louise Penny.
"A State of Terror"
is available now.